welcome everybody my name is Matthew
Kaiser and today I'm going to be talking
about some Gene panel validation
workflows that are new in DNA star
software
DNA Star as many of you may already know
as a company that produces
bioinformatics software we're located in
Madison Wisconsin we have a nice picture
of our Lake Monona here
DNA star has a long history in producing
software at a very high level our
developers our sales force is mostly
located here in Madison Wisconsin
and we've been in business for quite
some time in fact this year is our 30th
anniversary and we can see some a nice
picture here from 1984 we have our
founder Dr Fred Blattner who is still
working actively with the company and
coming up with great new ideas and some
of the folks here are some of our
developers that uh still work with DNA
star and develop new tools so we have
many many years of experience producing
the software and on a regular basis once
or twice a year we release new software
to provide additional tools for our
existing user base as well as new tools
for for people that are whether I needed
software
our software again we can track it all
the way back to 1985. uh it is research
grade software it is the most cited
bioinformatics software in peer-reviewed
Publications you can see uh as recently
as 2013 on DNA star software is cited
more than twice the next nearest
competitor so we've been in the business
for a long time we produce high grade
software the wide user base worldwide
and it's really been our goal to produce
software that that people can use for
research and
um and and publish of the the
the
data that they get with our software
excuse me
so with next-gen software
um
we can handle really any size of a
project and a variety of different
sequencing platforms and so these are
projects that can range in size from
targeted Gene panels to exomes to
genomes all the way up to multiple
genomes and so this can be a Lumina or
ion torrent or PAC bio Roche 454 or
traditional Sanger methods so the
software has to be designed to be
flexible enough to accommodate not only
different platforms but also different
workflows
and and so I'll show you some of the
interface today on uh how we can set up
projects and today in particular we're
going to look at accuracy measurements
and and how we can uh verify accuracy
when we're using um different platforms
and using uh different types of projects
so one of the first questions that will
come up is
um what is the the power of desktop
software so you know how can I use a
laptop or you know a two thousand dollar
desktop computer to handle these
extremely large data sets and so I like
to show uh this just this uh these
benchmarks that we have for a variety of
different data sets from Human genomes
to exomes to cancer panels amplicit for
mine torrent or true Sequim alumina and
of course these are different assembly
types where there's different numbers of
reads so Human Genome may have you know
1.2 billion reads as as what eight
exomes that we align all together and
the coverages vary as well so it's it's
uh you know from you know 36x coverage
and Human Genome all the way up to tens
of thousands of X coverage in a very
deep cancer panel and the assembly times
for these large data sets vary anywhere
from uh an overnight assembly 12 to 13
hours down to just minutes so some of
the smaller data sets of the cancer
panel might be 10 or 20 or or more
minutes and so the assembly in terms of
speed is excellent and I think that our
software could outperform just about
anything that's out there in terms of
speed of course when you're doing
variant analysis you also want to know
not only is it fast but is it also
Accurate Alignment and can we accurately
detect Snips or variants in these data
sets and that's really what the focus of
the webinar today is DNA Stars providing
researchers now a mechanism that they
can assess the accuracy you know of
their process of their capture and and
downstream analysis so that's kind of so
we're going to have new benchmarks then
in addition to speed benchmarks that
that can be based on accuracy and so our
snip prediction accuracy with Illumina
data is now greater than 99 percent
and this is really what we'll focus on
here and you can see the uh the
the footnote here to the side is that
this accuracy was determined using a
human genome na 12878 reference material
and that's what we're going to dig into
a little bit deeper you know when we
make a claim of accuracy that's near 100
um how do we do that and and is it
possible it's one thing for a software
company like DNA star to claim the
accuracy and then have a data set that a
researcher might not be able to get
their hands on or using a mechanism that
is statistically too complicated to to
calculate the accuracies uh what we've
done with our latest software version 12
software is we've put these tools in the
researcher's hands so that you can you
can determine this accuracy on it could
be the same reference data set that we
used or could be your own data set using
uh on your own set of Standards so we we
put the flexibility in the software to
allow you to do that
so when you use DNA star software for
um
next-gen sequence data you also want to
be cognizant of the hardware that you
may need to run the different assemblies
and this is just a basic schematic here
um it's it's meant to be simple and then
what I'm showing is that the ideal
configuration for alignments to a human
genome so this is exome or Gene panel or
whole genome data there's really a three
it's a three hard drive configuration it
is your computer's hard drive which will
run the operating system and the
assembly algorithm and that can be a
four core computer 16 gigs of RAM uh you
know pretty modest computer and then
there's a disk called a scratch disk and
that's what processes temporary files
and so that can vary in size one
terabyte you may need for Gene panels or
exomes one terabyte is going to be
enough if you're doing whole genome
analysis then you know maybe more maybe
up to four terabytes of space so so
that's a dedicated drive and then of
course storage for both the input and
output data if you're going to be trying
out a demo of our software
um and you need to want us to check your
Hardware to see you know if you have
sufficient Hardware that's something
that you can do with the sales rep we
can give you an idea of of the hardware
requirement for a particular project but
it's pretty simple Hardware these days
laptops often come with 16 gigs of RAM
so we're regularly running game all data
sets you know on a laptop computer even
even exomes can be run on on laptops
our software in addition to great
performance uh there's also a support
and a support varies there's uh there's
over a hundred videos on specific topics
on our website so if you go to the
support section you'll see you know ion
torrent or pecti or Illumina specific
workflows and these are usually you can
see from the screenshots here uh you
know five minute long videos that will
show in detail a particular workflow and
so this is a great source of of learning
what the software can do and how to use
the software
um
we also have webinars that we that we
host from DNA star on a regular basis so
this is about once a month and these
topics can range from Next Gen so I had
done one on Gene panel workflows a
couple months ago to you know basic
molecular biology my colleague Aaron did
a cloning and primer design back in July
and my colleague Farhan will have
another one next week on Sanger sequence
data alignment and editing so if you're
interested in different topics
you can also visit our website and these
are recorded and you can watch them from
the past three years now
so the software that we're going to be
talking about today is the laser Gene
genomics Suite this is a suite of
software that includes both the assembly
software that's sick man engine and then
the downstream analysis tools which is
primarily our seekman Pro and arraystar
softwares
and so the genomics suite then it's
available in all different kind of
licenses flexible licensing options
there are other packages that DNA star
offers that focus on things like
structural biology and protein folding
and phylogenetic type alignments and
then the basics you know cloning and
primer design so so our software we
really strive to cover both next-gen
sequencing workflows as well as the
basic molecular biology workflows
So today we're going to be talking about
a validation workflow that is part of uh
really it's it's typically used for
exome and Gene panel workflows you might
also use it in a genome or sequencing
workflow if you have a validated genome
and it's right now it's a subgroup of
our our Gene panel workflow and you can
see that our software is designed to do
a number of different uh projects so if
you are in a lab where you're doing
multiple things this is an ideal
software that can cover things like the
nobo assemblies with transcriptome or
genome data rnac you know as well as the
workflows that we're focusing on today
so one of the uh
aspects of our software that makes it
somewhat unique is that it can be used
to analyze a lot of different type of
experimental setups or experimental
designs and so you may have you know an
individual that you've sequenced where
it's just one individual and you want to
compare to a reference and look for
interesting Snips or you could have a
you know paired analysis of normal and
tumor or pedigree you just have a
handful of cohorts that you're comparing
all the way up to Association studies
and in our software we can handle these
different levels of projects Association
studies you know it may be that you have
a hundred exomes and and you know half
of them are control and half of them are
cancer and you're looking for genes that
are unique to the cancer group so we
have analysis tools then that can scale
up to very large projects and with the
assembly
assembly speed that we have
um you can do large projects you know in
a reasonable amount of time we'll have
some new options as well for these
larger if you if you are someone that's
doing Association studies and you've got
100 exomes that you have to do
um you know we have some other options
that will be uh available later this
year things like assembly up on a cloud
where you can use cloud resources to
handle these really large data sets so
that's something to keep in mind so we
can analyze these different sample sizes
and and really one of the challenges
then with any next-gen data set when
you're looking for variant analysis is
finding the signal amongst all the all
the noise and there could be noise from
the sequencing instrument it can be
noise from the alignment it can be noise
from the filters that are applied and
there's also the background just the
normal variations that occur you know
the 4 million or so that are unique to
each individual and so it becomes a
really big Channel then uh filtering out
the things that you aren't interested in
to find just those few variations that
are related to disease so you so you
have to have
um a great degree of accuracy then so
you want to make sure that you can
actually separate that signal from the
noise so accuracy really becomes more
and more important with these kind of
workflows
so one way uh to filter out uh
variations that aren't interesting is
the use of Gene panels and Gene panels
are used by you know all the different
uh sequencing platforms so ion tolerant
and alumina as well as custom panels and
what what their intention is is to focus
on hot spot areas and focus on on sets
of genes that are known to be implicated
with particular diseases and so it
scales down the project for you
essentially so to limit the sequencing
just to these just to these areas so now
for example ion torrent The amplicity
Comprehensive Cancer panel you know it's
it's targeting all the exons and 409
genes whereas the you know the Illumina
true site cancer panel a little bit
different panel you know it's 94 genes
and there's uh almost 300 Snips in those
genes that are known to have some give
some predispositions to uh different
cancers
uh and then of course we have custom
panels so you may be designing uh your
own panel or embellishing the panels
that are commercial and and using uh the
latest literature to find new potential
genes that you want to add to your panel
uh so if you're going to be doing panel
design work our software also provides
mechanisms to assess the accuracy of the
entire process is your targeting
efficient and then if you are targeting
efficiently are you finding all the
Snips that should be in those targeted
areas and so that's really what the
focus is today is uh how to validate the
process in a gene panel or targeted
resequencing
workflow now some of the important I
listed some of the files that are
important for this workflow that
includes the input data
the input data is usually a fast queue
file as a starting point or it could be
an underlined bam file if you're online
customer there's also a bed file that
specifies the targeted regions and a VCF
file that is really contains a lot of
information but essentially it's a list
of the high confidence Snips that are in
in your panel
um now of course the commercial vendors
will supply these files with their data
sets so you can download them but
there's lots of folks that that have uh
Custom Custom panels they may or may not
have a bed file or a VCF file you may
just have the Snips in a text format in
that case some minor formatting of a
text file can get it into a format that
is compatible with our software so I'm
going to talk about the bed file on VCF
in a little bit more detail here
I'm so bed and manifest files these are
typically tab delimited text files that
contain just the list so the First
Column is usually a chromosome the
chromosome number and then the start and
end position of each one of the targets
and they're produced by Iron torrent and
aluminum of both my bed files alumina
may also call this a manifest file for
some other kits and seekman and uses the
bed file as a filter so the aligner
isn't forced to align the sequence data
in these targeted areas the aligner is
aligns the sequence data where it best
matches and then you can use the bed
file then to filter and say for example
only show me the Snips that are inside
my targeted regions and so in many cases
that may filter out 90 percent of the
noise from an assembly which may occur
in more ambiguous alignment areas in the
genome and so the pedophile is very very
important then to use as a filter to
find what's interested interesting
excuse me
um we have a tutorial then that can show
someone how to convert a text file into
a bed file this is a pretty common if
you're working with this kind of data
you may very well have just a list of
Gene targets and so it is possible to
make a bed file from scratch if needed
the VCF files these are becoming more
and more ubiquitous and there's many
different sources aluminum torrent of
course but then also a thousand genomes
project the exome variant server other
software programs can all produce
variant call format files and uh seekman
engine our software can import a VCF
file and it essentially uses it as a
list of important positions or reference
positions and we can use that to
supplement the DB snip data so our
software can also read the 60 million
Snips or so from dbsnip plus a VCF file
that you provide to it and those kind of
are all treated as reference positions
or reference snip positions VCF files
also have additional information
annotation information we can utilize
that as well in our arraystar software
we can pull annotations in and then
decorate individual Snips on a snip
table using the VCF file information and
of course these can also be converted so
two very important for this kind of a
workflow very important file types in
this validation workflow the VCF files
are providing a list of the known
variants in a control data set and so it
becomes Central to the validation
process so the question of how is
accuracy determined in a gene panel uh
so I have a couple couple ways that this
is done uh the first way is how most
customers uh right now are doing things
at least the customers that I've worked
with uh usually uh folks that have been
in the business a while have a number of
data sets that have been sequenced you
know usually if you're Sanger where they
know that there are some verified
variations you know in some genes of
interest and generally what you'll do is
just run a next-gen run on that same
data set and see you know with my ion
torrent or my Illumina do I find the
Snips that I know are there
uh which which is a great you know of
course a very natural thing to do and
you want to do that to make sure that as
you move from saying or the next gen
that yeah that you're catching the same
Snips uh and this works okay on smaller
scales
um but the the the problem with this
approach is that usually there's only a
few verified Snips so you might have a
handful of genes and just a handful of
snips and it's not a large enough sample
size to really get a uh a feel for
whether or not it's accurate or not
um and and generally you're doing manual
calculations so you're getting a true
positive detection rate and not really a
good feel for false positive detection
rates and some other statistics that go
with it so we think that a better
approach is to utilize as large a data
set as possible
with your NGS data and in something that
has been sequenced with multiple
sequence methods so where there's
millions of snips or you can get a true
positive and false positive detection
rate and one of the ideal data sets for
this is the nist's genome in a bottle
data set and this is a human genome
that's been sequenced with multiple
methods and we'll talk about that a
little bit here so the validation
control is used to determine the
effectiveness of the gene panel
targeting so this includes how specific
are the primers how efficient was the
sequencing instrument what is the
accuracy of the assembler and the snip
collar and in addition to the Snips that
I recall are the filters that are
applied
and we can use the DNA star software
then to validate the entire process and
so this is where the control like the
nist gentlemen bottle is is ideal there
are other control data sets you may get
one from ion torrent or alumina they may
have a control using sometimes even
using the na 12878 genome so you
probably want to use both and see you
know do you catch all the Snips that you
should uh in a particular data set
so the genome in a bottle of the the
author of genome in a bottle is Justin
Zuck and this is uh Human Genome
na-12878 central European sequenced by
all different platforms to hide depth
and what genome in a bottle is then is I
have kind of this crude diagram the
green line is human chromosome one and
in human chromosome one there are some
regions that are difficult to get
accurate data and so the nist bed file
which is the red line shows the regions
on human chromosome one this is an
approximate drawing that can be called
or a Snips can be called a high degree
of confidence so it's you know it's 90
or so of human chromosome one so these
are regions where snip calls can be made
at a high degree of confidence and so uh
genome in a bottle and provides the bed
file so you know what the targeted areas
are and then provides all the high
confidence snip calls in these areas our
software will use these this bed file to
limit these snip calculations to these
high confidence regions now if you have
a gene panel which is much much smaller
it may just have some coverage over the
nist bed file we can make an
intersection that's the red rectangle
and actually make a smaller list of VCF
variations where
there's overlap between the gene panel
and the high confidence calls and genome
in a bottle so we can use those then to
determine the accuracy to find Snips
that are supposed to be there with with
this particular genome
so we've Incorporated
um because this is there's a number of
steps here that can be fairly
challenging for a researcher to come up
with on their own we've Incorporated
this validation workflow in our Gene
panel workflows that was offered with
with version uh version 12 software
earlier this year so our new Gene panel
workflows include a mendelian or
germline panel workflow as well as a
cancer somatic workflow and then of
course the validation process is its own
essentially its own workflow and that's
what I'll show you is how easy it is to
set that particular kind of a assembly
up and then do the downstream analysis
so seekman engine is the starting point
we use it to assemble the fastq files uh
cpan engine is a 64-bit program it's the
one that requires a scratch disk so this
is if you need to run assemblies you
want to put secret engine on your
sturdius computer and it has a a an
interface then that allows us to set up
these assemblies and that's a key
difference between secant engine and the
typical competitors for cpan engine
which are oftentimes open source
programs that may not have a user
interface at all
excuse me so seekman engine is designed
then to be as easy to use as is possible
to be flexible to allow for different
platforms and different workflows and
reproducible we can rerun a script if
needed to load and rerun the exact same
assembly that we ran on the previous uh
in a previous session
and so I'll just show you some of the
screenshots for what sequin engine looks
like and then some of the downstream
analysis so
now the starting point for seekman
engine is usually a new assembly project
and we click next on The Wizard and that
just brings us to the next page in the
Wizard where we can choose the project
type and you can see the list here is
growing if you're familiar with cpan
engine already this list keeps getting
longer as we find more project types of
course there's genome and exome and
version 12 we differentiate between a
mendelian germline panel assembly or a
cancer somatic Gene panel assembly and
when you start to make Selections in the
workflow
then it'll start to set different
optimal parameters for that particular
workflow so in a germline panel assembly
you know we're going to be expecting
Snips in heterozygous or homozygous
frequencies and so we apply slightly
different filters so the project uh the
the workflow hopefully allows us to set
up all different types of projects
without having to answer too many
questions that are difficult to answer
in the Wizard
so you choose the project type then the
assembly type
and again this is a new screen if we
don't have a control or if I don't have
a want to run a validation control I can
run a just a normal workflow and just
run a normal assembly however if I want
to run a control or have a validation
set I can select the templated
assemblies with a control
and then click next
and now it's asking for the template
file so what do you want to align your
data against for variant detection
and so DNA star provides a number of
genome template packages a genome
template package includes the the ncbi
annotated chromosome sequences those are
in genbank format
in the general template package also
includes
VCF files
or may include VCF files but it'll
include dbsnip database files Cosmic
cancer database you can add a VCF file
and I'll show I'll actually be in the
next screen at this point we can add a a
manifest file so we're aligning to the
whole genome template but we're only
interested in the targeted area so you
can see at the bottom of the screen I've
loaded a targeted regions file and it
couldn't be a bed file it can be a
manifest file and that just tells the
assembler that assemble will hold genome
but we're interested in these
sub-regions of the genome
the assembly options
now are default for the workflow that
we've selected so if we pick Illumina
data there will be a slightly different
mirror size and optimal match percentage
for example than there is with ion
torrent data and so
um so the wizard fills in some of the
optimal parameters for the end user
however the end user still has control
over things like minimum match
percentage and there's some Advanced
options here that I won't describe in
detail that allow you to tweak different
parts of the alignment algorithm
now prior to the validation controls
changing things from a default had some
carried quite a bit of risk with it DNA
star has run hundreds of assemblies you
know with these default parameters and
really determine that for that type of
data that's probably the best parameter
to use
um customers are often find that they
you know there's a misnip that they want
to change parameters so that may be done
uh without a validation if you change
for instance a match percentage to find
one snip in a data set you might
actually be missing or becoming less
accurate to optimize for one particular
variation in a data set it's kind of a
dangerous thing to do however with the
validation control you can change these
parameters and then get a statistical
measure across a very large data set to
to learn did you become more or less
accurate for all the data points in that
project so it's a really nice the
validation really allows us then to make
some changes from the defaults to see
you know do we get more or less accurate
with the particular data set that we're
working on so it's a great way to
fine-tune and optimize by using one of
these validated controls
so one of the uh so so once the assembly
is run
the
there's a number of reports that are
generated and the reports that are
generated
um give different bits of information
there's some overlap but different bits
of information depending on on what what
it is that you're interested in
so one of the first reports that's
that's useful is a gene panel targeting
report and what this is telling me is if
I've targeted you know a hundred genes
or or the exons in 100 genes did I get
sequence data aligned to all all of
those targets or and if I didn't can I
go and investigate why I made out of
covered a certain area so this is a an
interactive table and it is a report
then that lists all the targeted areas
so what we have in the in the First
Column is a contact number and then we
have the feature name and then the
location within the feature so this is
going to be an axome coordinate the
length so you can see these are all Exon
sizes the coverage depth so we have the
depth of sequence coverage across that
Target and then the percent of the
target that's covered and then an rpkm
value which is a normalized value and
then and then a read count as well
and so we can look at this particular
table and then sort it and for instance
in this particular table I sorted by
percent covered and so I could see that
in this particular panel that I've
gotten coverage on almost everything
except there's two exons here where the
percent coverage is less than 100
percent
and so when I'm designing a a gene panel
and maybe I'm adding a couple more exons
or there's a new Gene and I want to
embellish it so I design primers or
probes to capture these regions this
report can quickly tell me did I did I
capture all the regions that I intended
to capture so you're not going into it
blindly or you don't have to search each
Exon you get a report and you can see
from the two that I highlighted here
that the coverage depth that we have
less than a hundred but the coverage
depth is pretty low for these uh you
know only three or 20x so it's much
lower than the other captured areas so
it's possible that for this particular
region uh the the capture efficiency may
have been very low I didn't include a
screenshot here but there's also you can
see at the top of this table there are
tabs for targeted and not targeted
because seekman engine is aligning the
sequence data to the entire genome we
can also go look at not targeted and C
did sequence data align the areas
outside my carded area so for example
did I actually capture pseudogene and
sequence pseudogenes rather than my
genes and did the is the data actually
aligning to pseudogenes better than my
target so you can you can use uh this
report then to figure out you know first
of all did I hit all the targets and if
I didn't hit all the targets uh figure
out why all the targets aren't covered
so it's a really powerful tool for for
panels so this is just another view then
in seek man I know there's a lot going
on here but it's you can see the report
the targeted Report with the rb1 gene uh
just a targeted region selected seekman
pro has multiple interactive views so
we're looking at a a strategy view
which is the middle View and that
strategy view shows a depth of coverage
histogram and you can see the Y scale
there is there's a 5000 x deep and I
have it selected the same region in all
three views and so we can see then a
some green arrows there let's see if I
have a
let's make a little highlighter tool
here I think
so these little green arrows down here
um our exons their annotations on the
chromosome sequence
and so uh
maybe I'll try and arrow here instead
yeah that's better so there we have some
axons and you can see that there's a
depth of coverage then well over 5000 x
over one of the exons so in this
particular Gene we didn't Target all the
exons just a particular Exon
and if you double click on this report
we also get an alignment view so you can
actually go and look at the individual
line bases in detail so it's a great way
to go then and verify all the targeting
improve it if you see that targets are
missed you can go back and redesign some
primers and try to increase the
effectiveness of the targeting so so
that's one way to actually increase the
accuracy is to improve the accuracy of
the targeting itself
so when a a validated standard is used
another report that's generated is the
snip calling accuracy report and the
accessory report
um is generated from the standard that
was used so in this case if it's the
nist
na 12878 standard and you have a
targeted region
um our software then can generate an
automatic statistical report and this
goes back to the accuracy plan that we
have of 99.8 percent
um and this report will be generated in
our arraystar software so you run the
assembly say run validation report
and there's I just copied out a couple
pieces of this but you can see there's a
the first statement here is essentially
a summary statement and it's just saying
that you know given a minimum depth of
10 x coverage that that we're detecting
15 494 out of 15
545 Snips using a filter a probability
filter of 75 percent
and so we can get a feel for you know
how many Snips were there in our
validated data set you know so we have a
little over 15 000 and we're getting
most of them but what does that mean
exactly in terms of accuracy and how
many false positives there were that's
what can be more difficult to calculate
by hand and so our report automatically
generates uh this information so it'll
say the number of true positives
detected was fifteen thousand four
hundred ninety four there were 622 false
positives and from that information we
can calculate things like false
Discovery rate
which gives you an idea of how many
false positives there are and then we
also get sensitivity and specificity and
from sensitivity and specificity we can
get something uh called balanced
accuracy which is just
a simple calculation then
and you can see them from our data set
that we can calculate accuracy on the
genome in a bottle data set across a
large number of variations and that's
really what's key is we can then go back
and change some parameters for alignment
we'll see does this number go up or down
not optimizing for one snip in a data
set but really looking across 15 000
Snips of course this is a a 15 000
snitch so this is in a in a axome
analysis and we are also working to
generate some of the accuracy reports on
whole genome and get all the statistics
calculated for whole genome accuracy so
in areas that may not be as optimized as
Exon capture but in some of the more
difficult to assemble areas that are
found in the genome
thank you
so one of the last things that you can
do then when you when you run the
assembly in our software and get a
targeted report and then a a snip
validation report for accuracy our
software also provides a means to look
at the assembled data
utilize a snip report
and then visualize the Align data as
well so you can do a visual confirmation
this is particularly important if
there's something that you that is
missed so if you've got for example a
list of a hundred Snips in your data set
and you run a validation control and you
find that one of the hundred uh is is
not detected and there's coverage there
those are the kind of snips that you
want to have the ability then to to
manually investigate look at the
alignment and determine you know what
might be the cause and uh there's lots
of different you know why isn't the
accuracy 100 you know there's so that
last one percent or so uh there's all
different categories in that last one
percent and those are things that you'll
investigate you know it could be that
um there's an error in in the reference
that was used you know that that will
show up occasionally it might be that
the sequence data itself isn't generated
cleanly in an area like that it can also
be that the aligner the secret engine
aligner for that particular
um snip was uh not an optimal alignment
so the snip could be missed that way or
it could be a filter that was applied
that just filtered out at a threshold so
there's lots of different reasons but
you need to be able to look at the
assembly to be able to determine why a
snip was missed and so of course
internally we use this to to make our
software better we've got this huge
validated data set that you know we can
keep tweaking parameters and and trying
to get to 100 percent you know you know
looking forward for end users uh this is
a great tool then to you know find out
how accurate is their process are you
getting 100 or if it's not 99.8 if it's
something less than that you'll be able
to figure out why and then screenshot
that I have here you can see the seekman
snip report that is completely
interactive with uh the alignment views
and the way the snip report is
structured and I'll just kind of go
through a couple of the columns here but
uh you know there's reference positions
there is a reference base and a call
Base the the impact so there's a you
know impact on the protein we had to
snip percent
and then whether or not it's it's uh in
a region capture by default we filter if
you provide a bed file there's a default
filter applied to the snip report that
says only show the Snips in the capture
regions and so again this report has 11
positions in it so if I I could turn
that filter off and see you know how
much data is there outside to capture
there's also a DB snip ID
so this is uh all the DB snip snip
information that is uh has an RS number
so you can see that most of the Snips I
have in the snap table
um have been identified in r d snip
there are some in this column that do
not have BB snip identifiers these are
potentially novel Snips to to that
sample so we can apply different filters
to focus on novel or known Snips and
then we have a cosmic cancer database
with its own identifier The evolutionary
rate profile
information the girth and then the user
ID way over here on the on the right
side this is these are the actual Snips
in the VCF file that was used to
validate the process so these are Snips
provided you know of known verified
Snips in this case that I want to see if
we can detect them in a particular data
set so you can use this really nice snip
report then to filter through the
variations I can double click on any one
of these Snips and actually see
um
see the Align data in segment Pro so we
can see in this
screenshot of an alignment I have this
top sequence here the NC it's chromosome
human chromosome 4 and you can see the
gene annotation and all the different
mRNA and CDs annotations and then down
below we've got the Align data
um and what I have highlighted there is
a is a a gene a snip that occurs at 99.1
percent it's in DB snit and it's a
little more difficult to see highlighted
but the A's here are actually blue in
color so
um if you haven't used seekman software
at all
um it's top-notch software for looking
at assemblies large assemblies to human
chromosomes navigating through these the
assembly and I'm looking at the actual
line data to make validation so again
it's a great new workflow that we have
in DNA star software if you haven't
tried us out I highly encourage that you
try the new Gene panel workflows and
with that that's all I have today if you
have any questions I will stick around
here at the end of the webinar and
answer any questions that you have thank
you
thank you